so I'm Deepa mhani and today my goal is
to be able to answer what is databas
animation interactivity and linking how
can you get started with it in your
storytelling within quto itself and
finally have fun while we're learning
that together so there are lots of
amazing packages already that you might
have heard of some I've listed some I
might have missed but for the length of
this talk I'm going to focus on plotly
and cross talk but know that each of
those packages have unique strength for
the need that you're trying to
solve but first I want to talk about TED
lasso Ted lasso is a show on Apple TV uh
and apple is not paying me to tell you
that but there is an American football
coach that is invited to teach UK
Richmond soccer team or as the rest of
the world calls real football and in
that the captain is royen sitting on the
right hand side who absolutely loves to
say the the
word sorry sorry I'll try that again he
absolutely loves to say the
word looks like their AI powered
bleeping is working really well great
job guys so he loves to drop the f bomb
when does he do it well when he's mad
definitely but really in every modood if
you've seen taso this is his natural
mode so we want to look at the number of
times he drops F bombs now how do I know
this because I watched the episodes at
2x speed and diligently noted them down
including the gestures for
science so let's dig into the Meetup
let's talk about animation but first I
have a question for you what season do
you think Roy Kent ended up dropping the
most number of f bombs and whether
you've seen the show or not I do have a
hint for you this is the first episode
and how many F bomb he drops in the very
first episode of each season so season 1
2 and three it's 2 11 and six so if you
think it's season 1 raise your
hand you if you think it's season two
with the highest
count W and if you think it's season 3
raise your
hand all right let's find
out ooh let's see by the last quarter if
season 2 is going to recover or season 1
going to
recover and season 3 you all are
winners so what was I able to do with
the animation I was able to hold the
tension in the story while I was
bringing you along and I was able to add
a third variable to my story which is
not usually visible in a 2d plot the
third variable here was element of time
it was a season versus Count that's all
it was and I added that element of time
where you saw Episode by episode that's
what it allowed me to do now let's come
to the meat of it how do you do it this
is where I'm going to talk about plotly
package where I'm just going to talk
about a very simple bar plot I'm not
going to go into how do you prettify the
bar plot because I just want to talk
about the basic code structure of
animating something so this is your
simple barplot you've got a data set
from plotly you use a plotly function
give it the X and Y variable and simply
call add bars function looks kind of
pretty similar to ggplot if you if
you're used to that all you need to do
to this to make it animated is give it a
frame component within your ad bars and
what that frame equal to episode tells
it is that don't just reveal my barplot
as it is but build it frame by frame
when I click on the play button and
that's all that's needed to animate your
bar plan you can also tell it how long
to stay on a frame and how quick the
transition to the next frame should
be that's it now that we've talked about
animation let's move on to interactivity
and this is where we're going to get a
little bit techn technical cuz it might
we might bring up some statistic
Concepts but I'll hold your hand through
it we're going to talk about fscore and
some of you stat nerds might already
know this but let's talk about it anyway
an episode's F score is how many times
Roy Kent drops the f bomb divided by the
total number of f bombs in that episode
or in other words what's Roy Ken's
contribution to that total episodes F
bombs now I have another question for
you which season do you think has the
highest number of episodes where Roy
Ken's contribution was greater than 50%
or his F score was greater than 50% and
I have another hint for you so this is
the total count that we saw from the
previous animation plot so which season
do you think is the answer season
2 3 looks like you all are learning from
the last
quiz so I'm just going to reveal the
answer no animation here so this is how
I could display the bar plot where every
single episode and there could be
multiple more seasons could be plotted
in a single bar plot and you could hover
over it look at the episode and the
season that it's from and look at the F
score count or I could just add a simple
thing to make it easier to visualize
where let's just look at season 1 so it
has two episodes where the F score is
greater than 50% season 3 has got three
episodes with greater than 50%
and season 2 1 2 3 four episodes with
greater than 50% F score so season two
this time you all are the
winners now what was I able to do
through interactivity I was able to turn
my viz into a dashboard style report and
I know a lot of us have been asked can
that be a dashboard so this is a great
answer for that and you were able to
make your visualization more accessible
by adding filtering you could also add
filters like scroll bars where you just
see the fscore within a certain
range now the meat of it the code
structure I'm not going to dive again
into the simple barplot code structure
but a very quick recap of what that
looks like I am now going to introduce a
package cross talk now cross talk is
exactly what the package name says it
allows you to talk between the checkbox
and between the plot so the first thing
you do when you're using a cross talk
package is create a shared data object
that would be shared between those two
components how do you do that so we
created the bar plot on a data set
instead of doing that we will create a
shared data object from that data set
using cross Talk's shared data function
now once you've created this shared data
object all you do is create the same bar
plot that you had created but instead of
using data set you just use this shared
data object now what's the other thing
you need you need a
checkbox so let's cross talk has a
filter checkbox function where you you
can create a checkbox component you give
it a unique ID you give it a label which
is the heading you see you give it the
shared data saying that use this shared
data object not any data set and then
the grouping equal to season just tells
it okay what am I
highlighting and you just place the
checkbox and the plot side by side using
the b bs calls function and that's it
you have an interactive plot right
within your quarto presentation or quto
HTML any type of HTML like your website
or
document now let's talk about linking
it's another type of interactivity and a
lot of you might know of it as
brushing so I have another question but
we're not going to raise hands don't
worry this time U at some point
throughout the seasons royen starts
dating their PR manager KY pictured here
and at some point he starts coaching the
team so I wanted to find out whether
when he was dating did he mellow down
and the average F score go down maybe me
or when he was coaching did it go up
well I'm sure Ted Lazo fans must have
started guessing the answer here but I'm
going to reveal it right away so here's
the answer so when he was only dating
the average F score was 43% through
those episodes when he was only coaching
it was 39% but when he was dating and
coaching the average F score went up to
45% now this is fine I asked a question
I answered the question nothing wrong
with it but as Roy Kent said don't you
dare settle for fine and I'm wearing
that t-shirt as well cuz I'm channeling
my royant
energy so let's add additional insights
to this by linking it to another plot so
on the left hand side of the plot we
just saw and on the right hand side I
have the F count of every single episode
and every single season so let's say I
wanted to see where he was dating only
what are those episodes so I'm able to
highlight that real quick now let's say
I wanted to see the episodes where he
was was only coaching I'm able to
highlight that as well but let's say I
want to know that when he was dating and
coaching what are the episodes that
drove the F score to
higher the ambulance is want to know so
you can hover over this look at the
episodes that are highlighted and see
what were the F scores that were driving
it up was it because royen dropped F
bomb too many times or was it because
the episodes F count was just low in
general so you can drive more insights
like this
now what was I able to do I was able to
add layers to the story that I had
started with and I'm able to give my
stakeholders more control to arrive at
more insights than what they started
with now the code the structure of how
do you create this linking so again
we're going to start with the cross talk
package to create a shared data object
between the two plots so you've got the
shared data object created the only
difference this time is the key that
says okay dating or Cod coaching flag so
if I select on anything any episode that
has dating and coaching flag as yes
highlight all the episodes
simultaneously that's what this key
tells you to
do now you'll just create the simple
plotly plot that we had talked about so
this first plot is where I'm plotting
for the average sccore through episodes
and the second plot where I'm just
plotting the F Count versus uh each
episode and now you just place them side
by side using the subplot come on that's
it you've got a linked plot which one
thing highlights and the other thing is
highlighted by it you can also give it
how do you want the highlighting to work
so plotly has this very neat function
called highlight where you can say
persistent equal to True means if I
highlight something keep the previous
highlight on still on and off just means
if I double click turn it off if I click
once turn it on and the dynamic equal to
True means did you see that color bar
where I can click on the color and
choose what color I want to do
highlighting with that's your Dynamic
equal to
true now that you have all of these
amazing tools for animation
interactivity linking let's combine all
of it in one plot in other words don't
do that unless needed so I'm going to
still show an example so here I wanted
to animate F count and F scores side by
side and see if the trends over seasons
is similar so I can add animation season
over season I also wanted to give the
stakeholders ability to click on a
season and just dive into it and I
wanted to see okay if an episode has a
high F count does it mean they have a
high F score H Etc so there is so much
happening here that it gets a bit
chaotic when you use too many Tools in
one place so if you were planning to
make everything animated and interactive
stop try to think about how it moves
your story forward and how you can use
it better and if you're using it in a in
a better way where it moves your story
forward right within quaro you're able
to add tension to your story you're able
to add a third variable to an otherwise
2D plot you can turn some simple
visualizations into a dashboard style
and make it more accessible you can add
layers to your story and finally give
your stakeholders more control by
putting them in the driver
SE now some of the resources I wanted to
share was there's a GitHub repo for this
presentation where you can look at the
code I used to generate but there's also
a package where you can download the
data of fcon drop by royen and the
entire episode so feel free to go nuts
and finally I hope this makes you
believe that you can easily get started
with it and that's it thank
[Applause]
you thank
you we have one question for you uh I
guess not directly a quarter question so
the question is can you put these
animations and cross talk into shiny
apps yes yes you can you can I will make
it a quarter question you can also put
shiny in CTO um which uh there's some
blogs on my website linked at the bottom
that you can check out there's a Blog
about that as well but yes plotly and
cross talk is something you can easily
use within shiny as well thank you and
let's thank all the speakers of this
[Applause]
session